Hey, everyone, we are in chapter six, and we're gonna be taking a look at some of these work problems.
Series of questions here covering these learning objectives and some of the material that you're seeing in your quizzes.
So let's go ahead and jump into the first question.
Which of the following best describes aggregate or market demand?
So, aggregate or market demand is the horizontal summation of all of the individual demand curves inside of the market.
So what we're looking for here is gonna be something like that, and that's going to be C as our answer, the total demand from all individual consumers in the market.
So again, aggregate demand horizontally sums all the individual demand curves to create the aggregate or market demand curve.
To maximize profit, a firm should continue adjusting price until what?
And this is a theme that we talk about over and over and over in this course.
And that's going to be where marginal revenue is equal to marginal cost.
So the firm is always attempting to maximize their profit at that particular point.
We have the optimal pricing policy that showed that whenever we set marginal revenue equal to.  Let's do it here.
Marginal revenue is equal to price times one plus one over the elasticity of demand.
But we also know marginal revenue is equal to marginal cost.
So what we're trying to do, that's where the profit maximizing quantity is found.
So what we're trying to do is figure out that with the elasticity and price involved, to help us determine where we can equate these two things together.
All right, let's move to the next question.
A company lowers the price of a product from $50 to $40, and quantity demand increases from 1000 to 1400 units.
What's the price elasticity of demand using midpoint formula.
So the elasticity of demand formula that I'm going to use is Q2 minus Q1 over P2 minus P1.
Multiply that by P2 plus P1 over Q2 plus Q1.
So let's just plug in the information that was given to us.
1400 is our Q2, 1000 is our Q1, our price 2 is 40 and our price 1 is 50.
And again, multiply that by just a reciprocal of this and put the plus signs in there.
So 40 plus 50 over 1400 plus 1000.
Now that's going to give me 400 over minus 10.
We're going to multiply that by 90 over 2400.
This cancels down to 9.
This will cancel down to 6.
So we're going to have minus 1 times 9 over 6.
And that is the same as saying 1.5.
So we have a price elasticity of demand equal to 1.5.
That lets us know that this is price elastic.
For every 1% increase in price, I have a 1.5% decrease in quantity demand.
For every 1% decrease in price, I have a 1 point 5% increase in my quantity demand.
All right, let's move to our next question.
If a product has elastic demand, should the firm or what should the firm do to increase revenue?
So here we are going to be looking at a downward sloping demand curve and we're going to have our marginal revenue, or, excuse me, our total revenue.
So let's put quantity here, quantity here.  This will be price.
On the vertical axis, total revenue.
On this vertical axis, total revenue looks like this.
It's a bell shaped curve.
And then at the peak here, at that point, this is where marginal revenue is equal to zero.
That's where our total revenue is maximized.
And that is where the elasticity of demand is equal to one.
And so let's draw in our marginal revenue.
There we go.  So this is our marginal revenue curve.
So this says where the elasticity is greater than one.
So the elasticity of demand is greater than one.
So if we're trying to increase total revenue, let's just say that we're at this particular price and that particular quantity Q1, P1.
Notice what our total revenue is.
Total revenue is right here, TR1.
If we're trying to increase revenue, then we're trying to move up along that total revenue curve.
So we want to decrease price down to P2.
So here we want to move down to a lower price which will then increase our total revenue.
So that is going to be C as our answer, lower the price of that good.
All right.
A good has a price elasticity of demand equal to zero.
So the elasticity of demand is equal to zero.
How would you describe its demand curve?
This is a price elasticity in which the consumer is not responsive at all to any price changes.
So what we're looking at here is going to be quantity price, and we're going to put Q star there.
This is our demand curve.
This is what we're talking about.
With a price elasticity of demand where it's equal to zero, this is perfectly inelastic.
So here I can Change the price P1 to P2, P2 to P1 doesn't matter.
Output does not change.
The amount that we consume does not change.
So here we have perfectly inelastic demand.
In this particular market, you have something that people desire so much that you can charge them whatever you want and they won't change their quantity demand for that good when the price of coffee increases by 10%.  So let's do this.
We'll put P C is going to increase by 10% the quantity demand for creamer.
So quantity demand for we'll put CR for Creamer Falls by 4, 4%.  Based on this information.
Coffee and creamer are what?  All right.
See we have one goods price increase and then the other good is having a decrease in its quantity demand.
That lets us know that we are dealing with complements as our particular, as our particular type of product or particular elasticity.
In this case, this is cross price elasticity.
And with the cross price elasticity so good x good.
Yes, that's the way we're looking at this.
We're going to have the quantity percent change in quantity over the percent change in price.
And this is going to give us 4% over 10% which is equal to 0.4.
So we have inelastic cross price elasticity.  So a what?
So with that, every 1% increase in price in the coffee here causes a 0.4% decrease in the quantity demand of our creamer.
Okay, next question.
If the income elasticity of demand is equal to minus 1.2, what does that tell us?
Now remember, we don't take the absolute value of an income elasticity because we need to know what kind of good we're dealing with.
The same thing for cross price elasticity of demand.
We need to know what kind of good we are dealing with.
Whenever I see an income elasticity or whatever you see an income elasticity that's minus one or something that's less than zero, that lets us know that we're dealing with an inferior good here, inferior goods.
As our income increases, we tend to decrease the amount that we consume.
But if we have a decrease in income, we're going to increase the amount of the inferior good that we consume.
So it's kind of one of those weird things that happens, but it is definitely one of those things that we do see.
Okay, our last question here.
A product's margin is 25, so let's go ahead and write that in the product margin here.
The contribution margin is 25% and the firm raises its price by 4%.
So that's a price change and that's going to be equal to 4% there.
What percent drop in quantity can the firm tolerate while still maintaining current profit?
So this is a stay even analysis question.
So what we're going to do is put stay even quantity percent change.
That's a weird looking Q. I'm going to rewrite that.
So this is the stay even quantity that we're trying to find.
And I've been using this equation.
The percent change in price over the percent change in the contribution margin.
Or we can just put contribution margin down there.
We don't really need to put percent change, just put percent contribution margin.
Contribution margin.
But there's also the one where you do add in the percent price.
And I do detail out the differences between the two formulas in the video that I covered this with.
So let's just go ahead and put the 4 over the 25.
So this is the 4% over the 25%.
And then when we solve this down, we get 0.16, multiply that by 100% and we get 16% as our answer.
So D is our answer.
This is how much the firm can lose in sales while still maintaining its profit level there.
So 16% is our stay even quantity percent amount that we can lose.
All right, that is it for chapter six.  Hope you've enjoyed it.